yeah this given us another minor me me
me me to see letting us me me me hug i'm
at me gut so since I go see the bundles
and eager boy yeah drop the heck from
skipping my met the boy look alonely
wake up I'm sorry front from the limb
right design-wise your buddy my double
buddy I'm publicity-shy me sneaking up
old boy Wow flammable hobby that's the
google app accomplished one joy until
the convention juicer michigan all the
B's promised life this is my mind again
but the Kenna's oh man sorry Monsieur de
Bercy years French mention we have five
people who come together to make
satirical videos women and you foster
home hut if he think that in 20 or 30
years everyone in Germany will be fair
skinned and blue-eyed you're naive
[Music]
here's all I enjoyed this is a very
German district but we have very nice
neighbors really friendly we're all on
good terms Eunice is Sunday and as my
first my father he's pretty german I'm
less so he lined shot some video I've
always been keen on making videos but
you really need to have an idea or
concept to make something meaningful and
that people can relate to that Wilson ad
don don juan boy cousin and him and ear
lumps fin long as it took us three
months to come up with a name of our
group it had to be something that we all
liked and then we could all get behind
daddle tater is a combination of two
words dartle the German worked with date
the fruit and identity the german word
for assassin is ends on board air phone
shaft and the board dates are a symbol
of friendship of sharing service and the
assassin is the provocative counterpoint
your voice on the data and one of your
adding Tata of tea cup for foreign visit
something we often get together to
brainstorm we complement each other well
as we against no inside as it would in
Dawn's and you just said for our videos
we mostly draw on personal experience
I'm a woman I'm visibly Muslim so
obviously my experiences are very
different from those of the guys it's
the Olsen team
[Music]
this is fault wood tile this museum I
think there are stereotypes the
subservient Muslim girl the stupid
Muslim girl the underage Muslim girl
those are the things people imagine or
expect do miss Janice and that's not me
at all but it must be because I wear a
headscarf other people seem to find that
confusing is that what's your done by my
mother's hasha the people on kahan as I
studied the Bible and the Quran all
three monotheistic religions and came to
the conclusion that all three religions
are one of the same all three have the
same concept of a supernatural power and
for me Islam provides the answers that
bring all of them together and complete
them the others some of you don't dig up
I would describe myself as a very
contemplative person I think it's
important not to make judgments about
other people noob under the water
sometimes I find it difficult but who
doesn't can fish Oh Ganymede Mia viene
do you go to design discuss to endure is
Christians and Muslims who say that
Islam and Christianity are incompatible
from probably haven't spent much time
with a person of the other religions I
admit and a personal standard & Lomb
switched on for tom is a recitation of
the souris is very melodious Dodge
duster son Zing's Angus compns that the
sound puts you into a spiritual mood it
often happens that I say my own private
prayer when I'm standing next to him
[Music]
my jobless barkeeper and a barkeeper I
own a bar and I totally enjoy seeing
people have as good time does this
mention to shoot at sight even come yah
Mon scooter Darcy delicious culos we
thought it would look really cool it's
really accessible wait a flying carpet
in dates this is awful these ones issue
there things without any negative
connotations and we associated them with
Islam which has negative connotations
for a lot of people ganna my new kids
responded really well to it no problem
none baba decent does she quit on the
gun panco this is Berlin anchor where I
grow up just finishing took up
[Music]
here for plain nasty Oh uncle Michelle
slam holes on skate let's see punko
punko is everything Germany's pankow
more German and I look I would say
literally I didn't fit into the picture
at all absolutely she's bigger person
as if Chavez go Hoss I hated flying to
Syria or Jordan during the summer
holiday because I knew I would get brown
it darker Glen man had me at similar it
wasn't like I was always treated as if I
were different not real when you're a
kid it only takes two or three decisive
moments this culinary school there was a
song we used to sing sometimes the black
Peter is out and about would i'd always
be pushed into the middle of the circle
on the other kid were pointed me I
wasn't allowed to be truly germ that's
the feeling I have a little minute from
you but Alice I love my family more than
anything I love spending time with we do
a lot together a few as many nieces are
called innokin Lauder and I'm Uncle
Peter and she's been down kavita
dude yeah I guess I remember I counted
those beats once hey Jim de sus furbish
my that's right you did since their 99
their prayer beads I Susan jemima
commitment have you ever seen them in
church when you're with your mom nicosia
Kizzy there's similar to this those are
called rosaries it's almost the same
thing a [ __ ] fascist glacier Yasim in
a very young team motivation ish I don't
really talk about or discuss my religion
with my nieces they should have the
freedom to make their own decisions and
form their own views kangal aunty I have
met a lot of [ __ ] Mazzoni sonia tom how
should I put it whatever proselytize
hope this makes me sick yeah there's
nothing to do with Islamic values or
Islamic conduct let's assume I'm victim
gloom encoder my road to faith was a
short one so it's in yon when I was 17 I
started contemplating the world then
around Christmas 2008 I saw a movie
called Monsieur Ibrahim and the flowers
of the Quran with my parents one I said
to Demi's Dominator hey mama should see
the second I like telling it like this
because it's how it really happened
alone hey mom where's our Quran and then
I spent the whole week thinking about it
dama doesn't exist and then one evening
I lay in bed and thought God if you
exist since then let me know give me
some sign and for a whole week I was
bombarded with science
become a second and Estes feared Suzanne
bomb I remember being in Norway on
vacation being a matter the whole family
once they're coming on one night I was
outside looking at the stars and when I
went back inside into the dark cabin I
saw theater on a carpet praying in a
dart at amazon tipis and fitted under
that mr. Tyler he tourists sort of taken
a bag I didn't say anything to him
because he was completely absorbed in
prayer but I could see with my own eyes
that it was the real deal he was really
serious it's my sitters as I said
advanced mind that's how did it was the
key to your success I'm often asked that
today I look back and think of the
people think I'm letting me deanne wish
to grab Tom papa hot guns can see it was
very important to my dad we thought
about things when we were still very
young it's but it had it knows that we
learned German and Arabic his diet
leaven because he wanted us to have a
good future fighters he's convinced
artisphere Jana gotetsu qualms and for
hub this happen much i participated in a
video project for young Muslims i played
the part of a news anchor and i thought
the idea behind it was really worthwhile
for fun I often ask myself when will we
live in a society in which we don't only
talk about equal opportunity but
actually live it like in saunas yahoo
Laden borscht put an elite eight does
and shout us to escape I'm quit I once
worked with a panel of journalists there
was a discussion session they thought I
was really nice but they said we
wouldn't hire you with the headscarf I
understand but don't cough too
I had four daughters famous after me
freedom means being able to live as I
choose that I don't restrict others nor
am I restricted by them I mentioned this
I'm stranqer one decision my name is
Angus lankford does he miss that I
continue to live within the laws that
apply to everyone Diego mango decent
left side but at the same time I'm able
to experience inner peace not that I'm
able to follow my inner consciousness
and make my own choices I could think
for myself ending from you ask it you
want to cola sure yeah my cell has a bar
and of course he sells alcohol I can't
help him sell alcohol I don't do that I
also don't carry any alcohol helped him
stat crates or whatever kissel wormwood
of us offer my currently support I can't
support him in that way that's I see
alice and he knows all that and it was
never a problem problems or was of
course there are limits simply from a
religious standpoint if I was only you
resist ankle won't finish so my son
reason for me to go to Marcel's bar the
kind of place I'd never usually go is to
seem ourselves because he's a friend and
I'm really fond of him fire Valentin
deep Harbor so does he hear up on sue
for by Sean it means a lot to me that
they stop by at the van was organization
it shows that they care for them though
they know that I would never expect them
to come to the bar but they come any
welcome it's their way of saying we
respect and really appreciate what you
achieved we've created something for
yourself it's not our thing but we know
that it means a lot to you and that's
why we stop by if you provided under
sink on before buy it for you get back
mistakes of Saladin in time feeding me
smack d9 it's early
Jesus wish to realtor to finish United
boy John Mackey amando we realized we
had to create a counterbalance so that
people who might be toying with the idea
of taking that grim and dangerous step
might rethink it for decent education
Victor and Cheyenne movie not so fun
[Music]
Jesus Ian tootin finished big long the
small think someone should expose the
ridiculousness of these fanatics because
I don't want Isis to achieve its goal of
spreading fear and temperance
ill-advised and does this ungrateful
button
my dad when I get on great up the old
pongas gate Malcolm mm-hmm absolutely
sure especially when AMI appears in a
video wearing her headscarf then all the
guys who are against Islam react Islam
50 gun he's lugging my song I'm
concerned sometimes sure we saw what
happened to Charlie Abdul caricatures
were published and then the magazine
staff was murdered doggish Watson eases
clean tootin finished dish on this logo
Alan I'm not and I don't think any of
the others are afraid that something
will happen to us doesn't source we
think there's not much difference
between making videos that attack them
directly or standing on a public square
where a bomber can go on clomid or dog
buns are shown for often important
platform the dwarf omen we're convinced
that we have to keep on doing this
because otherwise they will win where's
Diesel's given you could say I'm a
full-time professional Muslims I've
deliberately chosen this path with you
ish power to the people i work with
muslims in need of assistance of course
that means radicalized Muslim sometimes
the problem is that they usually don't
view themselves as radical then we try
to figure out if it's really a
radicalization often it's not this is
only when I got a Harmond off as much of
the time the fear is greater than the
reality as did he really did
skip not a schmear statistic statistics
show that there are more far right wing
attacks in this country than attacks
carried out by Muslims but still the
focus is always on the Islamic sector
however you want to call it possessed
Ebola our attention is drawn in that
direction banking Zindzi Belize yet Oh
past people are encouraged to think that
way if the guy has a long beard or a
woman wears a headscarf people are
encouraged to be suspicious and we are
damaged by because that general
suspicion never disappears dustman angst
Hut I understand that people fear the
unknown pushd but I don't understand why
people react with aggression brutality
xenophobia I don't understand that okey
ANC's it's okay to feel a fresh but know
your fear and and what you are actually
a frightened off or details Europe is
not in the grip of terrorism there is a
danger but if you really think about it
rationally you're more likely to die of
alcohol poisoning we have a big problem
with drug abuse and traffic accidents
with cancer but people aren't afraid of
that why not that man's let's say yeah
neo-nazi goes to a doctor yeah okay yeah
you're right wing extremists no do
neo-nazi itís I'm sorry but you're a
neo-nazi I'm sorry but there's a simple
cure grow your hair out and right-wing
extremists are often called brown pigs
we could use a term like that
dusty go Shh the busy spider and cook so
far unknown on busting our Father I'm
sorry your name is mr. brown brown
that's good at this okay I have a
problem I hate Jews and Muslims I simply
hate everyone who isn't Germany when I
was a kid at Sunday school I always put
up my hand for the Christmas play I want
the main power please please so I'd be
in the spotlight I have to admit I've
always been a bit of a hand what's my
dad Suzanne im sue i'm sorry mr. brown
I'm very sorry but you have all right
itís hey Scotty Callie I lots of shots
penis what my techniques a lot of fun
she has enough even as a kid I loved
imitating Peter Lloyd to immediate fetus
Angus on all right is no round there
physically I'd say theater can do
anything he's very good at putting
himself into somebody else's shift
somebody can play a sleazy salesman
schools I'm good for real estate agents
guys like that I just hope seems like i
can play the straight man who's a little
sleazy it's all student networks well
what is distinction so yes let's cook
I'm really hungry I have eggs so do i
owns a big evening mrs. and how that
chair is really laid back everyone can
do what they like when they like well we
still share a sense of community through
good as some limbs the oil some point of
course we want to reach the Muslim
community or that are located project
but not just them it's not exclusively
for one or teammates because you also
want to speak to the greater community
fish net so much more important to us
locals so I think it's really good that
somebody in the group belongs to the
social majority claw of course I'm a
FEMINIST limbs or I take off my head
scarf for the sake of a job no you leave
a mom I live in the here and now and at
the moment I wear it out of conviction
haggis I don't even think about it
gently said it's Magnus fitness solid by
i like it i think it's great and I'll
keep it oh but that could change defies
me I don't know whether I believe in
another religion or philosophy in five
years maybe then I'll say hey the
headscarf is irrelevant to me no I don't
want to wear it anymore mrs caughell
hits and four I just don't know if this
Nikki man semester since my tag does
five ish miss let's give divide their
imbalances in the Muslim community just
as there are in the non-muslim community
Oh miss fitness class of course I don't
like it when I have to pray in an
unattractive room in the mosque because
I'm a woman babe mcconville skies fall
but I have to be in a place where rather
than practicing my religion and feeling
close to God I get upset that I have to
look at a mess well the men get to be in
a beautiful room in spite of men on I
for sure is
[Music]
finish if anybody was so when I have an
assignment for the university or need to
research something I go see my mother I
used to do that in high school too she's
a librarian which is lucky for me and
she works at the humboldt university so
i go there and she gives me access to
every conceivable data bank into books
and I've got a quiet place to work
solution and opted awesome we can classf
emission yo Peter let's bail when I'm in
New York I should definitely visit a
mosque maybe I can talk to the people
there that's something I'd really like
to do I'd steer moment' that when he
told us that he had become a Muslim it
was too late to do anything about it but
that was the moment when you say to
yourself as a parent depending on how
you react you'll either keep your child
or lose him owned and we wanted to keep
him behind him
[Music]
we have tons of [ __ ] stop us or just on
the tee spring is mentally she's reading
manga comic tava expedited year in
English toffee I'm tylers myers video
[Music]
your muzzle Hutton's a doctor let's
trick
they're pissed ish the next can knocking
nearly an inch thick subsetting it says
I think there are no limits to
creativity when people are being hateful
they even invent unbelievable new
vocabulary words and come to take he
gets Gascon perfect well not so I'll cop
to slumber it's the calm kommentarer
hardly any comments that make me think
why am I doing this on the contrary they
motivate me small TV n desperate that's
exactly the reason why it's so important
that we carry on
[Music]
thus if Tar Pits are is the breaking of
the fast right after sunset
[Music]
skip that one it's a fabulous is to make
you realize what it means when you have
everything when you give up things that
you are used to having for a while you
come to realize how truly valuable they
are and give sudam dancing goats aren't
bad
[Music]
this presents what I don't know where to
start this so much at least your father
laughed there's a Sun gun sight it's all
so uncomplicated boundaries are broken
with a smile certain boundaries that we
have in our German culture as much in
question like can I stay to dinner that
would be an impolite question for them
you simply assumed you'll stay you can't
refuse the special name is no one who is
your fog I think that's really nice that
can so nice King mom for this country
fitness robbers I have a hunch where are
you from comes in yeah not in right
[Music]
dude sitting video the idea for the
video what's something we'd all been
thinking about we asked ourselves what
is actually German and can you exclude
certain things like people often do toft
kamat vian and damaging we've decided to
focus on the issue of integration and
the demands that are made from the
various sides and we make fun of all
that you should know me the ball from
India log we need dialogue we have to
tear down barriers oh yeah it wasn't bad
i mean the barriers that people have in
their heads one be deemed from vienna
golf he gets Muslims have them Germans
have them the everyone has to find their
place in the world you demo so V and you
can only find your place with the help
of everyone else that's Ian nerve aid on
DS influx cancer moment here for a lot
nothing
kiss tribute alone and they'll come into
a credits measurement